[Music]
from traditional nomads to urban rappers
the piece of globalization is faster in
Mongolia than just about anywhere else
in the world
8,000 kilometers separate hamburg from
Olin bata for flicky of debts nah
they're worlds apart
uncle I want to better understand how
the world works in different places to
see what's different than in Germany and
how people in other countries succeed in
beyond the Lord is no no no no nothing
the German entrepreneur has taken a year
off to meet business people in other
countries people like cool aandava doors
she started Mongolia's first organic
cosmetics business
so the Mongolian market is probably not
so big or is it yeah it's very little so
we need to go global we have to in order
to be sustainable in the long term so
that was kind of no question for you
like yeah the vision was from the start
to create a brand and the product that
can be acknowledged and recognized
anywhere in the world
getting to that point has been a
struggle David or JH started out making
soap in her parents kitchen learning by
doing she built up her company very
gradually today she has over 50
employees most are women training and
promoting women is part of her mission
it's a natural soap one soap has to cure
for two months it's almost like
cheese-making okay so it has to breathe
exactly
we don't want to be that's
overnight success that eventually faded
away and and disappeared once you have a
team your your dream of all these like
bubbly sky cloud things turn into
reality because then you have to think
about how to keep your salary constant
and how to always every month give your
salary because you know that people
depend on you and you know that these
people have have families so I think the
more you grow the more fears you have
and all those fears are on an even
larger scale it's hard for startups to
gain trust among potential employees and
financers alike in a country that's
traditionally relied on the mining
industry David Dortch would never have
been given a bank loan without her
parents support her company wouldn't
have survived
Zhang's mikono it's a chance to find
co-founders who want to do the same
thing you're doing and there still
aren't very many of these people that's
also the impression I got here
what do you have to do Pia the country
has 3 million inhabitants and half of
them live here
that means you have one really big city
and a huge country where a few people
actually live you need to build
something here that quickly functions in
another market
something you can quickly expanse
there's no effects would be a mess
the few startup founders in the country
tend to concentrate on international
markets many ambitious young Mongolians
move away : Davao dodge studied in
Germany and the u.s. I haven't lived
here for 20 years but there's always
something that like draws me back and I
think especially with the countryside it
has just this magical special energy
that that kind of pulls you back
when she came back to Mongolia
she had trouble coping with the smog and
pollution
she developed a skin rash and started
looking for cosmetic products that were
chemical free
davit or studied international energy
management she worked on the
construction of Mongolia's first wind
turbine park
so you've been studying so long being
abroad gaining lots of experience in
this sector here
Why Why did you kind of kick that and
was going to complete different
direction cosmetics the main thing that
I started thinking is what is my
internal driving force and my driving
force was
really to use everything I've learned
with all the experience with living
abroad with even this sector because I
think our Ganic skin care and renewable
energy is the same it's the same ends
it's just a different means because it's
using natural forces it's using what
that nature gives us and putting it in
the most efficient and effective way
into an end product that serves the
people
she's reminded of why she's made the
decision she has every time she drives
out to the steppe to meet her suppliers
David or she loves the vast expanse of
land rolling towards the horizon and the
nomadic lives of the herds people
this is tea and they're saying that it's
very dried this year
so that's why the
yeah so that the area in general is too
dry
Mongolia has made quite an impression on
future of debts now
it's exciting to meet founders on my
travels and to meet people like coolants
they think in very similar ways
these people come from very different
cultural backgrounds but the way they
solve problems is the same they're not
easily thrown off course and they always
keep trying to get ahead this could
notice no matter where they come from I
think that's terrific
the next stop on his journey couldn't be
more different Hong Kong
[Music]